[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là est là on enchaîne les [ __ ] ne
vous inquiétez pas si vous aurez votre
place à plaire à vraiment mais là on en
scène les talents
oui jean louis est parti une nouvelle
semaine nouvelle rubrique ça s'appelle
stop quoi mais les fous ce titre n'a
raté vous allez voir je regarde la télé
c'est quoi quand il se passe un truc de
fou mais vraiment de malades
stop j'appuie sur pause c'est fou comme
ça ouais mais vous allez voir comme ça
sa valeur comme sont des pépites j'ai
commencé par recherche appartement ou
maison et vous allez voir
omar da fonseca qui fait sa petite
visite tranquille
stéphane va lui parler du prix de ses 47
mètres carrés dans le 15e arrondissement
moi j'adore ces pièces a assez on n'est
pas bien là mais si peu
dilater stop attendait de seconde s'est
coincé derrière j'ai aussi regarder koh
lanta avec des candidats qui sont venus
dans cette aventure pour aller plus loin
possible est venue de sa voiture pour
aller le plus loin possible a tonné le
second il faut quoi derrière la balle
cette nouveauté ans assistant de doc
gynéco j'adore en cinq minutes
d'émission il a dit plus de trucs que
doc gynéco et on envoie omar da fonseca
fort et pathé stéphanois là c'est très
drôle la photo tout nu qu'il a fait je
trouve ces tests est sympa on part sur
si j'ai un appel à gérard si doc gynéco
continuer maintenant très bien pour être
mise en relation avec un conseiller
commercial mais aussi au niveau des
factures que ça signifie cette mascarade
à vous appel en pcv s'y régale c'est
horrible j'ai très peur a témoigné ces
conneries sur ces news tous les jours
c'est l'heure des pros et tous les jours
pascal praud et vénère du coup cette
fois ci ces contrats chroniqueurs qui
balance une info sauf que ou psy il
avait oublié de vérifier sur l'info une
tribune et moi j'aime bien promettre une
main aux fesses tu es sur la toile à
catherine deneuve
on dit ça j'en sois qu'elle a dit gêne
qu'on mette une main aux fesses je crois
pas que catherine deneuve retrouves ta
phrase non pas parce que là tu à te
faire défoncer alors fais attention fais
attention vous avez dit n'importe quoi
c'est une comédienne qui a fait une
imitation de deux heures dans l'émission
le grand cactus est une parodie gelé
sous les yeux cette attention jérôme ah
ouais mais fair tation jérôme maintenant
pascal et les colères et regarder j'ai
honte mais c'est plus fort mais j'ai
bien oui il était attentionné en direct
vous dites n'importe quoi je vais moi je
suis kg
cette alerte gounon
je voudrais dire j'aime beaucoup de
garçons est très bon car tient très bon
ami à vous marrer jérôme qu'on embrasse
écrié pascal il dit ça mais jérôme tu
sera là demain venez passer ce saut vite
pascal mer descend c'est donc ça dans la
fois que vous venez ça va il est content
très content alors juste vous prenez le
cachet de doc gynéco ce soir-là bon non
merci
les amoureux de la langue française va
attendre ce moment avec impatience ils
sont là chez ea et angie fellous ni les
oreilles ouais au prendre du coton et de
l'alcool à 90 sont en panne un peu ici
et c'est l'heure de nick sa grammaire
on adore parce que la première ville est
par contre que je m'amusais à bath et
donc à point que personne parle ait eus
franchement il ya des pros crédit dans
l'air de tout de côté
genre je vais apprendre des petites
chorégraphies mais le poignant pas du
tout la vengeance est un plat
faire vous cela était pas facile on est
bons joueurs on lui laisse une deuxième
chance i'm like
la vengeance est un plat qui se mange
glacial alors j'adore cela
c'est tellement drôle et tu es drôle tu
es trop lente une étude le tee shirt et
drôle partout mention spéciale pour les
anges
on n'est pas sûr de la grammaire mais on
reste quand même sur du haut niveau
réalisé si tu me georges hibon qu alors
oui on regarde dans les yeux bagis je
peux plus ouvrir des ans les yeux je
peux plus regarder mimizan les yeux moi
je suis à la mujer dans les yeux à la
drogue il a jamais vu ses yeux nous non
plus et voilà après ses vrais amis de
non non non non cet été vous avez été
assisté aux matières oui absolument dis
bien assisté pas voir pourquoi entendu
voilà merci ans qu'elle soit ans y ont
consacré un numéro spécial au gign unité
d'élite et le gign s'est pas le vigile
de supermarché qui louche avec son vieux
chien qui bavent n'ont eux s'ils ont
décidé de t'attraper peu importe tout
parce que tu fais et monte attrapée
est-ce qu'il va les chercher doc gynéco
dit long sur le coup là c'est parti
berlin vous avez par le gign est sur le
point d'appréhender un suspect s'est
peut-être doc a il est 7 heures les
gendarmes vont tenter de surprendre le
trafiquant au réveil et dès l'entrée
première surprise en ouverture et
roubaix rouairoux verrouilleront foule
justement que fait ce trafiquant il en
train de regarder tpb il regarde un film
porno c'est il entre à liège des
insultes didier deschamps parce que
c'est quand même cool que benzema soit
pour l'équipe de france fois je vais
croire qu'ils regardent tmp regardez
ouais bah c'est peut-être que quand ils
écoutent peut-être là également il avait
de transit était bon tenez bien totalité
des cas le ferry de vous parler anglais
et à saintes et doux si je lis bien que
ça tombe bien dans les chroniques d'en
haut sur france 3 des touristes anglais
sont complètement paumé au milieu de
nulle part est sûre qu'ils tombent mon
lolo 4,5 sur 20 de moyenne en anglais le
speak french where are you going
mais de quoi lolo épaulé par michel
prendre
mesdames sur six générations mais de
quoi twitter
bon là c'est mort mais comment on va
faire
heureusement d'aidé arrive à la
rescousse et avec des néons parle
français par français est d'aider
pourquoi tu utilises un cheval alors
pour ça non avec le soir plus tard
[Applaudissements]
labelux tout ce qui s'est dit ah vous
n'avez voit on a tous et on à olivier
tallaron qui viendra nous voir qui était
justement sur le terrain il a toutes les
infos viendra de voir tout à l'heure
alors mais un petit mot avec sa terre de
pécs a alors fait que c'était psg om et
moi j'aime bien regarder les matchs que
personne ne regarde jordi un championnat
belge vostes n contre que mes jumelles
je suis arrivé sur le louper le plus
extraordinaire du football vous allez
voir ça l'amène doc gynéco et la météo
font du monde rapide au monde vers
mixité gbagbo
[Applaudissements]
10h02
gascon mais si je viens de voir que le
mec il est quand même numéro 40 de
l'équipe servir lui quand ils ont fait
rentrer servir tout mon label candidats
dans les guillemets sandy west et rithy
panh a déjà vexé d'appeler on a le
numéro 46 pas rentrer les sardines enfin
c'est embêtant puis devenu plus dur
qu'on pense à un moment donné tous les
matins je commence à bosser ma chronique
environ vers 6h du mat et j'adore les
rouges qui jamais mieux six ans mais
parce que on bosse on est trop dans les
papiers nous qu'est-ce que vous n'aurez
pas pierre emmanuel savoir regarder la
matinale de bfm tous les jours à 6
heures coeur je vous jure que c'est vrai
il ya un mec qui choisit une musique
différente pour mettre sur l'âme et
aimerait s'appelle david guetta de la
météo du coup en fonction de la chanson
qui est choisie on sait exactement
l'humeur du gua et aujourd'hui vous
allez voir il teste pas ce bo5 à reims
aujourd'hui dans l'audi dernier jour de
la semaine est tout content c'était
bloqué depuis vendredi dernier à ses
rôles
17 à marseille 20 à nice
les nostalgiques et repenser au bon
moment avec son ex l'accession du abba
8 à auxerre nancy strasbourg
[Musique]
dimanche il a vu son index et elle est
refait sa vie avec son meilleur ami du
coup mauvais délire
mais ce matin il a retrouvé sourire on
dirait qu'il n'a pas dormi chez lui
qu'aucun à 17 à nice et bastia
tout chez la chatte à
et
[Applaudissements]